hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and uh basically ever since
i did that youtube groups video you guys
have been uh really asking and uh trying
to find out how do you set the image for
a youtube group the logo that everyone
sees when you display it on your channel
and i was unable to answer that question
for a long time because i really hadn't
found a way
but i just found out how to do that um
basically by accident but um i'm just
gonna scroll down here on my channel and
uh i also wanna give a big shout out to
all my subscribers i just reached 2 300
subscribers so thanks so much guys
um but anyway i'm going to scroll down
here to my youtube group which has uh
this classy little uh logo right here
that says hd tutorial so kind of catches
people's eyes so people are asking you
know how do you get that to be your
group logo um so i'm just going to go
ahead and visit the group i happen to be
the owner of the group and as far as i
know you have to be an owner or a
moderator to do this to the group so go
ahead and uh click on the group
and the url of course for my group which
has 300 members uh will be in the
description and please feel free to join
if you want to
so you'll see the featured video right
here is the top rated video but that's
not the point the point is how do you
set the logo for the group just go ahead
and uh if you're the owner of the group
or a moderator like i said just go ahead
and show discussion like this so you get
this grid sort of form
and i'm just going to scroll down and
you guys will see every time someone
submits a video you'll see this is this
is going from oldest to newest here you
have right under it use as group image
so it was purely by coincidence that i
got that but you can just scroll down to
any video you like and find one that you
like the thumbnail of and just go ahead
and say use as group image so i scrolled
up a few pages and found the intro made
by pablo and he's actually a member of
the group submitted the video himself i
didn't have to add it
and i went right on ahead and said use
as group image and that is exactly what
shows up on my channel so now if someone
uh were to visit the group or to visit
my channel you would see that as the the
the group logo and also over here inside
it says hd tutorials that is the same
logo that shows up on your channel so
yeah that's basically it guys that is
how you set the logo for a youtube group
and uh the you know the group image that
everyone sees when it's featured on your
channel and i hope this tutorial helped
you so uh thanks for watching this one
and stay tuned for the next one catch
you guys later peace